Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先快速告诉大家一件正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师Lisa Johnson共同举办的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战赛。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
还有丰厚的奖品等着你，由Lisa亲自颁发。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会为你提供所有详细信息。好了，让我们开始今天的内容吧。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. It can be so tricky in the middle of busy lives to find ways to cope with what life throws at us whether you are working with clients whether you are juggling work commitments and family commitments and just life laundry stuff it can be really really tricky and finding ways that can be useful for our own mental health and well-being and also that of our clients can be really transformational and sometimes trying on different approaches for size can be really useful ahead of doing that with your clients and there's lots spoken in the media about mindfulness and its benefits. And today I'm going to be joined by Amy Polly, who is a mindfulness expert. And I hope you will find our discussion around how she got into it, how she uses it for her own family and for her clients to be really, really useful. I will look forward to catching
如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。Aspiring Psychologist播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。你好，欢迎收听Aspiring Psychologist播客。在忙碌的生活中，想要应对生活抛给我们的难题真的非常棘手，无论你是在处理客户问题，还是在平衡工作与家庭的承诺，亦或是处理琐碎的家务，这都可能非常非常困难。找到对我们自身心理健康和福祉，以及对客户有益的方法，真的可以带来巨大的改变。有时在应用到客户身上之前，先尝试不同的方法看看是否适合自己是非常有用的。媒体上有很多关于正念及其益处的讨论。今天，我邀请到了正念专家Amy Polly。我希望你们会觉得我们关于她如何接触正念，以及她如何将其应用于家庭和客户的讨论非常有用。我期待着在节目后半部分与你交流。
up with you on the other side. I hope you find it useful. Hi, welcome along. Today we are joined by Amy Polly, who is a mindfulness expert. Hi, Amy, thank you for joining us. Hi, thank you for having me. Oh, so good to have you here. So I thought it would be useful for us to share with our audience a little bit about you and how you got into mindfulness if that's okay yeah of course so I always tell this story this is my origin story for mindfulness um I was going through a period of stress so I in my previous uh life not really not that long ago I was an accountant for nearly 19 years um and at the time I had quite a stressful job that was running around in my mind a lot of the time and I was in a relationship that wasn't very healthy for me.
希望你觉得这很有用。你好，欢迎。今天我们邀请到了正念专家Amy Polly。你好，Amy，感谢你的加入。你好，谢谢你的邀请。很高兴你能来。我想，如果能和我们的听众分享一下你的经历以及你是如何接触到正念的，应该会很有帮助，可以吗？当然可以。我总是讲这个故事，这是我接触正念的起源。当时我正经历一段压力期，在我不久前的“前世”里，我做了近19年的会计。那时我的工作压力很大，脑子里总是转个不停，而且我当时处于一段对我来说不太健康的恋爱关系中。
And so I was really, really stressed. And the first thing that I really noticed is, and I don't know about you, but it's affected my sleep and it affected my eating. But the thing for me is I know I can function without a bit of food, but without my sleep, I'm not OK. And it got to the point where I just wasn't falling asleep very easily. And I wasn't sleeping well. And I'm pretty sure that it must have been a middle of the night Google, where I thought to myself, so I need help with this. And I came across meditation and mindfulness, and I stuck something on YouTube. And I always say this is no word of a lie. Within about three or four days, I just started to drift off easier into sleep. And the quality of my sleep was just a little bit better. And at that point, with my mind, I just needed to know everything. So I bought a book about mindfulness. I started watching videos on YouTube and that was nine or 10 years ago now.
所以我真的感到压力巨大。我首先注意到的第一件事是——不知道你是否也有同感——它影响了我的睡眠和饮食。但对我来说，我知道我可以少吃点东西，但如果睡不好，我就无法正常生活。后来我甚至到了很难入睡的地步，睡眠质量也很差。我敢肯定，那一定是在某个深夜，我谷歌搜索了一下，心想我需要这方面的帮助。我发现了冥想和正念，于是就在YouTube上随便找了个视频看。我敢发誓，这绝不是谎话，大约三四天后，我开始更容易入睡了，睡眠质量也稍微好了一些。那时，我的大脑渴望了解一切，所以我买了一本关于正念的书，开始看YouTube上的视频，那已经是九十年前的事了。
So as I started to delve into it more I signed up to do a diploma in meditation I signed up to do a diploma in mindfulness and then it's almost like this gateway to a whole new world of understanding yourself and looking after yourself um and my nanny had dementia my mum had suffered with depression um and me going through my own journey I sort of told her all about it and so we sort of went on that journey a little bit together and I helped her and every time I'd learn something I'd go and sort of practice with my mum um and it just really changed things for me it changed my perspective on things it changed the way that we dealt with
随着我深入研究，我报名参加了冥想文凭课程，又报名了正念文凭课程。这就像是通往一个全新世界的大门，让你学会理解自己并照顾自己。我的保姆患有痴呆症，我妈妈曾患有抑郁症。在我经历自己的旅程时，我把这些都告诉了她，于是我们一起踏上了这段旅程。我帮助她，每次学到新东西，我都会去和妈妈一起练习。这真的改变了一切，改变了我看待事物的角度，改变了我们共同处理问题的方式。总而言之，这真的让我大开眼界，改变了我的生活。所以，那是九十年前的事了。现在我们在这里，我决定以此为基础开展一项事业。这是一个不可思议的故事。确实，我脑海中浮现的词就是“改变人生”。对于那次随意的谷歌搜索，听起来你当时在工作和思维混乱中确实承受了很大的痛苦。这确实引导你走上了一条非常有趣的道路，不仅帮助了你自己，也帮助了许多其他人。这确实是我的热情所在，因为它对我帮助太大了。我想，我上周和另一位正念老师交流时，情况也是一样。他也有自己的经历，在我开始之前，我从未想过我会教别人这些。我当时只是为了自己，然后分享给妈妈。但随着我们有了这些经历，你不断意识到它对你的帮助有多大。比如，我在生儿子之前流产过，如果我当时没有已经练习了一段时间的正念，我想我不会处理得那么好。生活中还有很多其他事情，我在生完儿子后患上了产后焦虑症。同样，我妈妈在那里支持我，但在自我支持方面，我有我的正念练习。我认为人们觉得这是一个“玄学”词汇，提到正念，他们就觉得“哦，就是保持头脑冷静和冥想”。其实不然，它远不止于此。它确实是一种练习，就像大脑训练一样，让我们的大脑能以更好的方式处理生活中的烂事。它并不总是完美的，我仍然会生气，仍然会难过，我仍然会失去理智，我仍然是一个普通人，但它确实对我帮助太大了，我无法不与他人分享。是的，你说得对。我认为有时因为媒体的关注和报道，它可能会让人们望而却步，因为它看起来确实有点“新时代”。
things together um and all in all honestly it was just eye-op opening and it was life changing for me. And so, yeah, nine or 10 years ago, that was. And here we are now and I've decided to run a business based on it. That's an incredible story. And absolutely. The words in my mind were life changing, you know, for that, that random Google um you know sounds like you were really suffering um quite a lot at that time with what was going on in your work and just mind mind fog um and that's really led you to a very interesting path that helps not only yourself um but loads of other people as well and it really is my passion i think because it helped me so much and i think it's a lot i've spoke to another
它看起来确实有点像水晶疗法，但它不需要那样，对吧？它可以是主流的，成为你日常生活的一部分。是的。你知道吗？我总是说“清空大脑”这种说法完全是胡扯。我去年被诊断出患有ADHD，所以我甚至不知道为什么我的大脑是这样运作的。了解这一点非常有趣。但我知道我有一个非常爱说话、嘈杂的大脑，它以文字和图片的形式思考，我的大脑从来没有安静过。即使在冥想时，我也必须以某种方式进行。而这种“清空大脑”的说法，我认为人们觉得正念、冥想就是清空大脑，感觉完美而宁静。事实并非如此。正念是……
mindfulness teacher last week we had a little catch-up and it was the same for him he had his journey before he I never knew I would want to teach this to people I was just doing it for me then I was sharing it with my mum but I think as we have our experiences and you keep having those moments of realization about how much it's helped you um you know I had a miscarriage before I had my son and I don't think I would have dealt with that the way that I did if I hadn't already had a mindfulness practice that I'd been practicing for quite a while um and lots of other things that happen in life I had postnatal anxiety after I had my son um again my mum was there to support
对当下发生的事情的觉知。正念不仅仅是冥想。我们可能会用冥想来进入一些良好的状态，是的，以某种方式呼吸会让我们平静，可视化练习也会非常美好和放松。但实际上，你某天做冥想时，可能会注意到你的呼吸很浅，胸口很紧，因为你感到焦虑。那是清空大脑吗？那是平静吗？不。那是正念吗？是的，因为那是觉知。所以我认为我们需要回到教育人们什么是正念以及它如何帮助我们的起点，在我们的日常生活中，它不是……
me but also in supporting myself I had my mindfulness practice and I think people think it's like this woo-woo word and people say mindfulness and they just think oh it's having a calm mind and meditating and it's not it's so much more than that it really is a practice it's like a brain training to allow our brain to deal with basically the shit in life in a better way um and it doesn't always it's not always perfect still get angry I still get sad you know I still lose my mind sometimes and you know I'm still a human being but it's just helped me so much I couldn't not share it with people. Yeah I think you're right I think sometimes I think because of the media attention and the press it's got, it can scare people off a little bit because it does seem a little bit new age.
那种我需要去山顶坐着，像你说的那样摆弄水晶——尽管我家里确实有几块水晶——但它不是那样的。它不是彩虹和独角兽，它是一种大脑训练，让你能够意识到你周围和内心正在发生什么。当我们有了这种觉知，希望管理这些事情会变得容易一些。是的，我认为这是一个很好的区分，欢迎人们无论处于什么状态都能加入。我知道我刚开始了解它时，它确实吓跑了我，我甚至退出了我的正念课程。因为那时我正处于实习的第三年，也就是最后一年，他们说……
It does seem a little bit crystal healing, but it doesn't need to be, does it? It can just be mainstream and part of your everyday life. Yeah. And you know what? So this whole thing I always say is BS, this empty your mind thing. I was diagnosed with ADHD last year, so I didn't even know this is why my brain is the way it is. It's been really interesting to understand that. But I know that I've got a very chatty, noisy brain that sees in words and pictures, and I don't have a quiet brain, like ever. Even in meditation, I have to do things a certain way. And this whole empty your mind thing, I think people think mindfulness, meditation, empty your mind, I feel perfect and serene. And it's literally not that. Mindfulness is the
“你需要每天花一小时躺在地板上一动不动，基本上要取消你所有的计划。”我当时想，你知道吗？我真的没有时间也没有意愿去做那个。我一年前刚和现在的丈夫同居，当时生活很忙，我还没有孩子，但如果我有孩子，那绝对是不可能的。所以我认为……
awareness of what's going on at the end of the day. Mindfulness isn't just meditation. So we might use meditation to get into some nice states. And yes, breathing in a certain way will calm us. And visualizations can be very lovely and relaxing but actually you might do a meditation one day where you notice that your breathing is shallow and your chest is tight because you're feeling anxious is that emptying your mind is that calm no is it mindfulness yes because it's awareness and so I think we just need to go right back to the beginning of educating people on what mindfulness is and how it can help us but in our everyday life like it's not
这可能与教学方式有关，不是作为日常的碎片时间，而是作为一个标准的“一小时”。是的，你知道吗？这让我有点愤怒，因为我觉得我想让它变得易于获取，我希望人们把它作为一种练习，所以我不想劝退人们。说到底，谁不想有一个小时躺着保持安静呢？但现实是大多数人没有那个机会，你仍然可以获得益处。我知道大脑是如何运作的，你不需要躺在那里一小时保持安静也能获得益处。我认为这是我们需要打破的最大误区。
this big I need to go to a mountaintop and sit like you say with crystals although I do like a few crystals in my house um but it's not that it's not rainbows and unicorns it's a brain training to be able to be aware of what's going on in and around you and then when we've got that awareness hopefully it's a bit easier to manage those things yeah I think that is a nice distinction just to welcome people in wherever they are right now um I know when I was first learning about it actually did scare me off and I did actually quit my mindfulness course um because I was in my third year as a trainee at that point third and final year, and they were like,
我的意思是，当我为我的生意命名时，我称自己为“正念叛逆者”（Mindfulness Rebel），叛逆就是我的生意，因为它打破了那些常规，特别是在心理健康和福祉方面。实际上，我开始练习时每天只花三分钟。也就是冥想，有意识地选择每天冥想三分钟。这是一个开始。每天进行小练习比偶尔进行一次大练习要好。那不是习惯，对吧？所以对我来说，特别是与很多妈妈合作时，关键在于我们如何将其融入日常生活？是的。有意识地选择坐下来冥想非常重要。这就像去健身房，为我们的大脑健身。
well, you're going to need to spend an hour a day sort of laying still on the floor and cancel any plans you've got basically. And I was like, do you know what? I haven't actually got time or the inclination to do that. I'd moved in with my partner who's now my husband like a year before when I was having a busy life I didn't have children at that time but if I'd had children that certainly would have been a no-go you know and so I think it was just something
如果不锻炼肌肉，你就练不出六块腹肌，同样，我们的大脑也需要锻炼。你可以，我总是这样说，你可以走路而不是开车。你可以走楼梯而不是坐电梯。那是你的日常练习。那是你日常照顾身体健康的方式，而你的正念日常练习就是你在那些无聊、平凡的日常任务中所做的事情。你不必坐一小时，但你可以在刷牙、洗澡、吃饭时练习正念——天哪，我们根本不这样做——或者散步、洗碗，无论是什么，你每天都可以练习正念。对我来说，这就是我们仍然需要打破的最大误区。好的，我想我们的很多听众……
about the way that that was taught not as everyday chunks of time but as a standard you know hour yeah and do you know what it infuriates me a little bit because I just think for me I want to make it accessible and I would I want people to have it as a practice so I don't want to discourage people from doing it and at the end of the day wouldn't we all like to have an hour to lay down in silence and whatever but the reality is that most people don't have that opportunity and you can still reap the benefits I people don't have that opportunity and you can still reap the benefits I mean you know how the brain works you can still reap the benefits without having to lay there for an hour in silence and that's I think for me the big thing that we need
至少有时间每天刷两次牙，所以你能给我们讲讲在那两分钟里如何做到真正的正念吗？当然。在解释之前，我其实在一家慈善机构工作，也就是我当地的心理健康慈善机构。来那里的人通常是由某人推荐参加我的八周课程。所以我白天做志愿者工作，进行临时咨询，然后为那些可能需要一点帮助的人开设八周课程。这些人心理状况不太好。有一次我们在聊天，正在进行课程，其中一位女士对我说——因为我当时在谈论刷牙，这是我……
to bust I mean when I was naming my business mindfulness rebel was what I called myself and rebellion is my business because it's just breaking those norms especially around mental health and well-being and mindfulness. And actually, I started my practice with three minutes a day. So a meditation, consciously choosing to meditate for three minutes a day. That's a start. And it's better to have a small practice every day than to have a big practice every now and again. That's not a habit, is it? And so for me, especially working a lot with mums, it's about how can we incorporate this into every day? Yes. Consciously choosing to sit in meditation is really important. That's like going for the gym, going to the gym for our mind.
总是提到的例子，我想是因为我真的很喜欢它，因为它有这么多不同的感觉。她说：“是的，但这和你说的坐在外面看漂亮的树或花是不一样的。”我说，这完全一样。我说，你的大脑并不知道它在关注什么。坐在外面看着美丽的风景可能让你感觉更好，但你的大脑激活前额叶皮层时，并不知道它是看着美丽的彩虹，还是看着你在刷牙。这就像一个小小的顿悟时刻，她说：“哦，好吧，所以我可以两者都做。”然后我们谈论了如何做到……
You can't get a six pack without exercising the muscles, the same as, you know, our brain needs the exercise. And you can, I always say it like this, you can walk instead of taking the car. You can take the stairs instead of the lift. That's your everyday practice. That's your everyday looking after your physical health where your mindfulness everyday practice is what you do in your boring mundane everyday tasks you don't have to sit for an hour but you can practice mindfulness when you're brushing your teeth having a shower eating your food god we don't do that at all you know having a walk washing up the pots whatever it is you can practice mindfulness every day um and that for me is like the big myth busting that we still need to do okay so i think many of our audience
这一点。所以当我们刷牙时，或者做任何事情时，关键在于尽可能多地激活我们的感官。对于像我这样大脑非常活跃的人来说，有时把过程稍微描述出来并标记出我能闻到什么、尝到什么、听到什么会有帮助。但关键就是回到那些感官。所以当你刷牙时，很多感官都被激活了，你可以闻到牙膏味，尝到牙膏味，听到牙刷在牙齿上的声音，你有触觉，无论是牙刷在牙齿上还是在手里。这只是关于回到所有那些微小的感官，真正专注于所有这些事情。当你这样做时，你就非常活在当下，你极不可能去想待办事项清单或昨天发生了什么。
are having time at least to brush their teeth twice a day so could you talk us through how you might be really mindful in those two minutes um morning and evening sure so i am actually just before i explain that i I work for a charity so my local mental health charity so people that come along there are usually prescribed by someone for my eight-week course so I do volunteer work during the day drop-in sessions then we have the eight week course for people that need to maybe have a little bit of help with things so these are people that aren't mentally well and I was having a chat and we were doing a session and one of the ladies said to me because I was talking about brushing my teeth it's one that I
你知道我的意思吗？所以这真的是关于把你的注意力带回到当下，这听起来有点像“哦，我该怎么做呢？”但这就是我们开始在日常任务中使用感官的方式。我认为这比学习用葡萄干练习要容易接受得多。是的，顺便说一下，我确实做葡萄干练习，只是因为它确实是一个很好的练习，特别是如果我在网上教学，我知道人们可能能拿到葡萄干或坚果之类的东西。但我总是讲我旅程刚开始时的故事。我已经练习了一段时间的正念。我对一位同事说：“哦，有一个正念经理课程，我们去吧，因为我们也许能为人们做这件事。”
always go to I think because I really like it because it's got so many different sensations and she went yes but it's not the same as you know if paying attention to sitting outside and looking at the nice tree or flowers or whatever and I said it is exactly the same I said your brain doesn't know what it's paying attention to it might feel nicer for you to be outside looking at a beautiful scenery but your brain engaging that prefrontal cortex of your brain doesn't know if it's a beautiful rainbow or if it's looking at you brushing your teeth um and it was almost like a little light bulb moment she was like oh okay so I can do both um and then we talked about how to do
即使在当时，显然我内心深处也有一些想要开始分享的东西。我只记得——这完全不是针对那个人，他非常可爱——但坐在酒店会议室里，一个穿着灰色西装打着领带的男人站在那里，让我去“听”一颗葡萄干，这真是我经历过的最有趣的事情之一。所以我做葡萄干练习，但我从不要求任何人去“听”它。这到现在还让我发笑。我不会说太多，不，但以防人们在听这个节目，他们会想“我甚至不知道你为什么在谈论葡萄干”，你能给我们一个关于葡萄干练习的非常简短的概述吗？葡萄干练习确实只是一个关于觉知的例子。这是我们开始冥想课程时做的第一件事，只是为了向人们展示他们是多么缺乏觉知，因为你可能从来没有真正……
that so when we're brushing our teeth for example or anything it's all about engaging as many of our senses as possible um and for someone with me like a really chatty mind sometimes it helps me to almost narrate it a little bit um and label what I can smell what I can taste what I can hear um but just coming back to those senses so so when you're brushing your teeth, so many of them are being activated, so you can smell your toothpaste, you can taste the toothpaste, you can hear the sound of the toothbrush on your teeth, you've got the sensation of touch either onto your teeth or in your hand, it's just about coming back to all those micro senses, like really honing in on all of those things, and you do that you are so present in the moment you are very highly unlikely to be thinking about the to-do list or what happened yesterday
研究过一颗葡萄干。就像我说的，通过观察它、触摸它、品尝它，我们正在使用我们所有的感官。所以这只是一个让人们参与正念的方式。特别是如果你让某人坐下来做这件事，你如何向他们展示觉知？我们使用葡萄干。太棒了。我感到很受鼓舞，因为无论我们看着什么都不重要，只要我们在做这件事。因为实际上，我的浴室仍然是家里唯一需要翻新的房间，所以它没那么漂亮，但在那里练习正念对我来说，和在瀑布旁练习一样有益。我喜欢这个，这真的很好，真的很好。所以，你知道，我们的听众很多时候都在管理巨大的病例量，有临床风险需要管理，他们有……
um do you know what I mean so it's really about bringing your attention to the moment which sounds a little bit like oh how am I going to do that but that's how we start using our senses in everyday tasks and I think that's so much more get on boardable with yes than learning with a raisin you know oh by the way right I have to say I do do the raisin just because it is a really good thing for especially if I'm teaching online I know people might be able to get a raisin or a nut or whatever it is um but I always tell the story of right at the beginning of my journey I've been practicing mindfulness for a bit. And I said to one of my colleagues, oh, there's a mindfulness managers course. Let's go, because we might be able to do this for people.
主管的压力，来自家庭和生活的压力，这很多。你知道，你有没有什么绝招，关于如何通过使用正念来减少和管理倦怠？是的，有几件事。正念是一件主动的事情，我们应该建立一种练习，这是第一点。如果你对正念感兴趣，我会说先开始，看看外面有什么。你甚至可以去YouTube，看看有没有课程。但这是一个练习，所以做那些主动的事情非常重要。与其等到压力大时才说“我现在需要正念”，不如在一切都好的时候练习它。所以实际上，当你身处瀑布旁，或者外出游玩，或者在热水浴缸里，或者无论你在做什么……
Even then, obviously, there was something within me that wanted to start sharing. And I just remember and I'm not this isn't about the guy at all. It was very lovely. But sitting in a hotel conference room with a guy standing there in a gray suit and tie telling me to listen to a raisin was honestly one of the funniest experiences ever so I do the raisin exercise but I never ask anyone to listen to it it still makes me laugh now I'm not gonna say very much no but in case people are listening to this they're like I don't even know why you're talking about raisins could you give us just a very quick overview of the raisin exercise um so the raisin exercise really is just an example in being aware so it's one of the first things we do when we start a meditation course just to show people how unaware they are because you've probably never really
在美好的时光里也要调动你的感官。开始对它产生兴趣。尽可能多地冥想。顺便说一下，并非所有的冥想都是一样的。有些人的声音真的会让你心烦。所以如果觉得烦，请随意关掉它，尝试另一个，因为这真的很重要。如果有人让你感到烦躁，不要咬牙切齿地坚持下去。所以我想说的是，我们需要投入主动的工作。就像我说的关于六块腹肌，不锻炼肌肉你就练不出六块腹肌，正念也是一样。我们需要进行练习，我们需要养成一个新的习惯。但我会说，从基础开始，在日常生活中保持觉知，每天选择一个小型的正念冥想。
studied a raisin and like i say it by looking at it by touching it by tasting it we are using all of our senses um and so it's just a way to get people to interact with being mindful especially if you're getting someone to come and sit down and do this thing how do you show them awareness we use a raisin brilliant and i'm really heartened with the idea that it doesn't matter what we're looking at so long as we're doing it because actually my bathroom is still the only room in the house that needs to be refurbed so it's not that nice but it's going to be as beneficial for me to be mindful in there as it is if I am by a waterfall you know doing love that's really good to know really good to know so you know lots of the time with our audience you know they're managing big caseloads there's you know clinical risk that they're managing they've got you know supervisor
但是当我们完成正念课程后，我们开始意识到正念不仅仅是冥想和觉知。它确实让我们开始了解我们的大脑是如何运作的。关于觉知的一大重点是，你会更了解自己，我也会更了解自己。我会更清楚什么事情会触发我的焦虑，我会知道什么事情会触发压力，我会知道哪些是导致倦怠的信号。例如，我们需要觉知来注意到这些事情，这就是为什么主动的正念练习效果很好。但在课程中，我们还会谈论其他事情，比如管理我们的反应，因为我们的大脑运作速度极快，我们会对事情做出膝跳反应。让事情顺其自然是另一个……
pressure pressure from family and home life it's a lot you know how could you know have you got a top tip um for how to kind of reduce and manage burnout by using mindfulness yeah so a couple of things really mindfulness is something that's proactive and that we should create a practice so that's the first thing if you're interested in mindfulness I would say just get started have a look what's out there you can even go on youtube you can see if there's courses but it's a practice so it's really important to do that proactive stuff so rather than just going I need mindfulness now because I'm stressed out actually practicing it when everything's all good so actually when you are by the waterfalls or you're out on a day out, or you're in a hot tub, or whatever you're doing,
我们谈论的大领域。因为特别是如果你压力很大，就像你说的，你有这些病例，你有客户，你有担忧，我们必须回到现实。正念的一大部分是对正在发生的事情有觉知，并进行现实核查。所以我总是问的问题是：我无法改变什么？我无法控制什么？试着让那些事情顺其自然，试着放下那些事情，实际上把我们的时间、精力和注意力投入到我们能控制、能改变的事情上。这在心态和能量分配上是一个巨大的转变，因为我们可以坐下来为很多事情发愁。我们可以为很多事情感到压力，但大多数时候它们已经发生了，或者它们肯定还没有发生。实际上那个问题，我认为这是正念的一大部分，就是思考我们的觉知、注意力和能量……
but being engaging your senses in the good times as well. And just starting to get interested in it. Meditate as often as you can. By the way, not all meditations are equal. Some people's voices will really annoy you. So feel free to turn it off and try another one, because that's really important. Don't sit there like gritting your teeth to get through it if someone's irritating um so what I would say is the proactive work we need to put that in you know like I said about the six pack you're not going to get a six pack without exercising the muscle and mindfulness is the same we need to make a practice we need to create a new habit um but what I would say is so start with the basics being aware in our every day choosing a small mindfulness meditation each day.
流向哪里。所以我们可以向自己提出这些问题，特别是如果我们开始感到压力时，比如“我为什么感到压力？这是真实的吗？这真的是现实生活，还是还没发生的事情，或者是过去发生的事情？”因为那不是现在的这里。这有道理吗？是的，确实有道理。我们会被那些可能永远不会发生，或者不在我们近期未来的事情所卷走，对吧？这真的很容易。当我经历那个无法入睡的时期时，我会开车时一直在琢磨已经发生的事情，那会引发我对未来的担忧。我从来没有真正活在当下。那种琢磨确实是我陷入负面思维和焦虑螺旋的原因。我现在学会了，开车是我思考很多的地方。我现在尝试即使在开车时也练习正念。我不知道人们在因超速被抓后会做这种练习。我只是在过去几个月才发现，你只需要标记出你能看到的东西。这就是关于那种保持注意力并把自己带回当下的过程。而且，你知道，这并不全是玄学。这只是关于训练你的大脑去做这件事，因为每次你的思绪飘走，你把它拉回来关注眼前的事情时，你就已经练习了正念。所以我……
But when we go through a mindfulness course, we start to realise that there's so much more to mindfulness than just meditation and just being aware. It really allows us to start to understand how our brain works. And one of the big things about awareness is you'll get to know yourself a bit more and I'll get to know myself a bit more. I'll know the things that trigger anxiety in me more I'll know the things that trigger anxiety in me I'll know the things that trigger stress I know the things that will be um flags that are leading to burnout for example we need awareness to notice those things that's why the proactive mindfulness really works well um but as we go through the course you know we talk about other things like managing our reactions because our brain works super quick and we knee jerk into things um letting things be is another
总是说没有所谓的“失败”。如果你在冥想时，人们说“我做了一次糟糕的冥想”，没有人会做糟糕的冥想，你只是冥想了。每次你的思绪游离——因为有时你会坐下来冥想，你会觉得“哦，我关注了呼吸，今天做得很好”——另一天你会觉得“哦，我的大脑就是静不下来”。但你已经在思绪中游离了一次，然后又把它拉回了冥想。给自己一点鼓励。每次你这样做，你就已经练习了正念。
big area that we talk about because especially if you are stressed out like you say you've got these cases you've got clients you've got worries we have to come back to the reality and a big part of mindfulness is having an awareness of what's going on and having a reality check so the question I always say is what what can't I change what can't I control? Try to let those things be, like let those things go and actually put our time, energy and focus into the things we can control, the things we can change. And that's a really big shift in mindset and in where your energy is going, because we can sit and stew on a lot of things. We can stress about a lot of things, but most of the time they've already happened or they certainly haven't happened yet. actually that question and I think that's one of the big parts of mindfulness is thinking about where our awareness attention and our energy is
是的，我想当我与人们合作，我们做了一些正念或引导意象之类的东西时，当他们走神时，他们对自己会很刻薄。但关键在于在没有批评的情况下轻轻地把自己带回来。这就是我总是说的“轻轻地”。是的，这指向了我们正念课程的后期部分，同情心和善意是一个巨大的领域。我们谈论你如何照顾自己，你如何善待自己？它不断出现。我们一直这样说，这需要练习。但你有时对自己说话的方式，绝不会对你最坏的敌人那样说。
going and so we can pose those questions to ourself particularly if we're starting to feel stressed like why am I feeling stressed is this real is this actually real life or is it something that hasn't happened yet or happened in the past because that's that's not here now um does that make sense yeah it really does it really does we can be swept away can't we by things that that may never happen um or are not within our immediate future and it's really easy you know and when I was going through that time when I couldn't sleep I'd be driving along in my car stewing stewing on things that had happened and that would then be informing worries that I would
它确实回到了同情心和善意，给自己一点作为人类的余地。我认为人们经常想：“我要练习正念和冥想，它必须是完美的，因为那是我们在Instagram和Facebook上看到的。”事实并非如此。我们是拥有人类大脑的人类，大脑的某种连接方式是为了保护我们。
be having about the future. Never was I very present in the moment. And that stewing was really what led me down that spiral of, you know, negative thinking and anxiety. And I've now learned, you know, driving is one of the places where I think a lot. And I now try to just practice mindfulness even when I'm driving. And I didn't know this was done in courses where people have been caught speeding and stuff. I only found that out in the last couple of months that you just label what you can see. And it's about that paying attention and bringing yourself back to the moment. And, you know, it isn't all woo woo. It's just about training your brain to do that, because every time that your mind flitters off somewhere and you pull it back to pay attention to the thing that's right in front of you you've just practiced mindfulness and so I
我们现在不需要那么多保护了，但仍然有触发我们的事情。我认为我们正念练习的一大重点是拥有对自己同情心，接受我们是人类的事实。事情不会总是按计划进行，我们会犯错。这没关系。我只是觉得，你知道，社交媒体和经常在线让我们觉得我们不允许犯错，但我们绝对可以。就像你说的，关键在于善待自己。没有失败，没有错误，这只是一个练习。你知道，大多数时候人们做这个练习是因为他们想更好地照顾自己。所以，是的，善意和同情心非常重要。你提到的其中一些事情，你知道，当你因为过去的事情或即将发生的事情而难以保持在当下时……
always say there's no like failing if you're sitting in meditation and people say like I've had a bad meditation no one has a bad meditation you just meditated and each time your mind wanders off because sometimes you'll sit in meditation and you'll feel like oh that was I paid attention to my breathing and I did that really well today another day you'll think oh, oh, that was, I paid attention to my breathing, and I did that really well today. Another day, you'll think, oh, my mind just didn't settle. But you will have gone somewhere in your thoughts and pulled it back to the meditation. Give yourself a pat on the back. Each time you've done that, you've just practiced mindfulness.
这实际上是创伤的症状，对吧？而对未来可能发生的事情的过度警觉症状也与创伤有关。所以通过真正努力保持在当下，我们真的在努力帮助大脑、身体和心灵知道“那不是现在，那是过去，或者那是可能发生也可能不发生的事情”。这也会非常有益。它确实影响了我们的神经系统，你知道，你确实知道身体和大脑运作的方式是，我们实际上并不知道我们是否真的处于那种情况，还是在思考处于那种情况。我们仍然会释放那些压力化学物质和……
Yeah, I think when I work with people and we've done some elements of mindfulness or guided imagery type stuff, people can be quite mean to themselves when they wander off track but it's about that gently returning yourself without criticism that's the word i always yeah gently yeah and and that you know that nods to when we get to sort of the latter part of our mindfulness course compassion and kindness is a huge area that we talk about how are you looking after yourself how are you being kind to yourself? And it keeps coming back. And we say it all the time and it comes with practice, but you wouldn't speak to your worst enemy the way that you speak to yourself sometimes.
荷尔蒙。所以实际上，在生理上，擅长活在当下对我们非常有益。因为当我们开始思考那些事情，或者把自己带回一个可能是创伤性的地方，或者只是一个普遍压力大的地方——比如对我来说，当我患有产后焦虑症时，处于那种状态——我能感觉到身体里的那些感受，生理上确实发生了什么。所以我认为，你知道，我们经常像我之前说的那样认为正念是那种在完美安静空间里做的“玄学”东西，但事实并非如此。它在帮助我们管理心理健康方面非常有用，而且这也会影响我们的身体……
And it does come back to compassion and kindness and giving yourself a little bit of leeway for being a human being. I think people often think, you know, I'm going to practice mindfulness and meditation. It has to be perfect because that's what we see on Instagram and Facebook and whatever. And it's not. We're human beings with a human brain that is wired a certain way to protect us.
健康。如果我们开始把心理健康作为一个整体来思考，我开始为我领导的课程创建一个工具包。你知道上面会有什么吗？我们谈论饮食，谈论睡眠，谈论人际联系，但正念处于核心位置，因为我们必须拥有那种觉知才能做所有其他事情。所以，是的，它真的可以改变人生。我知道你之前对我说我不显老之类的，但我认为部分原因只是我一直在照顾自己。而且，你知道，压力会让人衰老，对吧？并不是说我从来没有压力，但我只是觉得有时我们只是接受了这些高水平的压力。
We don't need that so much nowadays, but there's still things that triggers us. And I think one of the big things about our mindfulness practice is having that compassion for ourself to accept that we're human. And things aren't always going to go to plan and we're going to make mistakes. And that's OK. I just think, you know, social media and being online a lot of the time makes us think that we're not allowed to make mistakes but we absolutely are um and like you say it's about being kind there's no failing there's no wrong um it's just about a practice and you know most of the time when people are doing this practice it's because they want to look after themselves a little bit better um so yeah kindness and compassion is huge some of the stuff you mentioned there you know when you're struggling to stay present in the now because of stuff from then or stuff from that's going to happen.
但这样做实际上可以学习一种新的管理方式。这就是我想为人们做的事情。是的，我喜欢这一点，它对你的思想、身体、灵魂都有全面的影响，所有这些。而且，是的，它可以改变人生，就像它对你一样。它确实改变了，我真的不知道如果我没有那个练习，在那些非常困难的时期，在我个人生活中发生的那些事情中，我会怎么做。我简直无法想象。我无法想象没有它，我只是无法想象，我不知道我会怎么做，我只是不知道我……
It's actually, you know, symptoms of trauma, isn't it? And then symptoms of hypervigilance about what's going to come is all tied up in trauma as well. So by really trying to stay in the present, we really trying to help you know the brain and the body and the mind know that's not now that was then or that's gonna be what may or may not come to pass and that can be really useful as well well it really affects our you know our nervous system and you know well you do know the the way that our body and our mind works is that we don't actually know if we are in that situation or if we're thinking about being in that situation we still release those stress chemicals and
会怎么做。这就像是为未来做准备，对吧？现在学习这些东西，以便以后在路上需要时——也许是在你甚至无法想象的时刻——你已经在银行里存了这些东西，你已经准备好了。是的，而且你知道，当我患有产后焦虑症时，我一生中从未有过焦虑，我从未有过类似的事情。这与我宝宝的出生有很大关系。而且，你知道，我的正念练习帮助我的其中一件事，不仅仅是正念练习，而是我意识到我需要帮助。因为我非常了解我通常的思维和感受方式，以及我的情绪，我能看到正在发生什么，我意识到我“不好了”。所以我确实获得了一些额外的帮助。即使是去年，我还在进行治疗，因为我……
hormones so actually it really is beneficial for us physiologically to be better at being present in the moment because when we start to ponder on those things or take ourself back to a it could be a traumatic place or just a generally stressful place or for me for example when I had postnatal anxiety being in that space like I could feel those feelings in my body like that physiologically something was happening and so I think you know often we think like I said before that mindfulness is this woo woo la la thing that we're going to do in a perfectly quiet space and it isn't it's really useful in helping us to manage our mental health but also that impacts our physical
认为我有那种对我的“基准线”的觉知。当我意识到我的练习没有帮助我时，它确保了我确实去寻求了更多的帮助。是的，它教会了你那种觉知，对吧？我喜欢你说的“基准线”，你瞄准的“正常”，这对每个人来说都不同，对吧？是的，绝对不同。但你知道那不是你“茁壮成长”的状态，你觉得你还有更多可以给自己的。而且，你知道，你和你小儿子之间这种新的关系，也可以为它注入能量，帮助一切流动得更顺畅。是的，我们正在努力。这仍然不是……我的意思是，封锁并没有帮助，因为我的很多焦虑实际上是关于……
health and if we start thinking about mental health as a whole I started to create a toolkit for the sessions that I was leading and you know what's going to be on there we talk about eating we talk about sleep we talk about human connection but mindfulness sits at the core because we have to have that awareness to be able to do all of those other things so yeah it can be really life-changing and I know you said to me earlier about not looking my age or whatever, but I think part of that is just been looking after myself. And, you know, stress can be aging, can't it? Not to say I never have any stress, but I just feel like sometimes we just accept these high levels of stress.
离开家。所以我有了朋友。这是关于正念的另一个重要点，实际上是沟通。我不害怕沟通，我明白我可能需要沟通什么，虽然并不总是——我的ADHD大脑也不擅长这个。所以这是互惠互利的。但我会和朋友谈论它。他们开始向我敞开心扉。我甚至不知道我的一些最好的朋友正在经历她们正在经历的事情。当时有人，我们刚生完孩子不久，她说：“我感觉完全一样，除了我在室内呆在家里的时候。”所以我们有相同的症状，但触发点完全不同。
But it's doing so can actually learn a new way of managing it. And that's what I think I want for people yeah yeah I love that it can have a total impact on your mind your body your soul um all of that and it's yeah it can be life-changing like it has been for you it really has and I honestly don't know what I would have done in those really difficult times those things that have happened in my personal life if I didn't have that practice like I just can't even imagine it I can't imagine not having I just I just can't I just don't know what I would have done I just don't know what I
但这样做实际上可以学习一种管理它的新方法。这就是我认为我想要为人们做到的，是的，我喜欢它能对你的思想、身体、灵魂产生全面的影响，嗯，这一切，而且它确实可以改变生活，就像它对你所做的那样。它真的改变了，我老实说不知道如果我没有那种练习，在那些我个人生活中发生的非常困难的时期，我会怎么做。我简直无法想象，我无法想象没有它，我只是，我只是不知道我会怎么做，我只是不知道我会……
would have done it's like future-proofing yourself isn't it learning the stuff now so that when you need it later along the road perhaps at times you can't even imagine you've got that in the bank you've got that ready yeah and I and you know when I when I had postnatal anxiety so I've never had anxiety in my life I never had anything like that it was very much linked to the birth of my baby um and you know one of the things that my mindfulness practice also helped me with wasn't just my mindfulness practice it was the awareness that I needed help because I was so in tune with how I usually thought and felt and my emotions and I could see what was happening and that it I was not okay and so I did actually get some additional help um even still last year I was working through and had some therapy um because I
会怎么做。这就像是为未来做准备，不是吗？现在学习这些东西，以便以后在人生道路上需要时，也许是在你甚至无法想象的时候，你已经有了储备，你已经准备好了。是的，你知道，当我患有产后焦虑症时，我一生中从未有过焦虑，我从未有过类似的情况，这与我孩子的出生有很大关系。嗯，你知道，我的正念练习帮助我的其中一件事，不仅仅是正念练习，而是我意识到我需要帮助，因为我非常了解我通常的思维、感受和情绪，我能看到正在发生的事情，我当时的状态并不好，所以我确实寻求了一些额外的帮助。嗯，即使是去年，我还在处理一些事情，并进行了一些治疗，因为我……
think I had that awareness of what sort of my baseline if you like and when I knew that my practice wasn't helping me so it made sure that I actually went and got some more help as well. Yeah yeah it teaches you that awareness doesn't it and I love the idea of what your your baseline is you know normal for aiming yeah which is different for everyone right yeah absolutely but you knew that that wasn't you thriving um and you felt that you had more that you could give yourself and um you know this new relationship that you've got with your little boy um you know to supercharge that as well and just help everything flow that much easier yeah we're getting there it's still not it's still you know it was only I mean lockdown didn't help because a lot of my anxiety was around actually
我想我有了那种意识，知道我的基准线是什么，当我知道我的练习无法帮助我时，它确保了我确实去寻求了更多的帮助。是的，它教会了你那种意识，不是吗？我喜欢你所说的“基准线”这个概念，你知道，那是你追求的“正常”状态，这对每个人来说都是不同的，对吧？是的，绝对是这样。但你知道那不是你蓬勃发展的状态，你觉得你可以给自己更多，而且，你知道，你和你小男孩之间这种新的关系，你知道，也要给它注入活力，帮助一切变得更加顺畅。是的，我们正在努力，这仍然不是……你知道，这只是……我的意思是，封锁并没有帮助，因为我的很多焦虑实际上是围绕着……
leaving the house so I had friends this is another important thing about mindfulness actually is communication I am not afraid to communicate and I understand what I probably need to communicate not always my my ADHD brain also is not good at that. So it's give and take. But I would talk to friends about it. And they'd start to open up to me. And I never even knew some of my bestest friends were experiencing what they're experiencing. And someone at the time, we'd not long had our babies, you know, from each other. And she said, I feel exactly the same except when I'm indoors and staying at home. So we had the same symptoms, but the trigger for us was completely different.
离开家。所以我有一些朋友，这实际上是关于正念的另一件重要的事情，那就是沟通。我不害怕沟通，我明白我可能需要沟通什么，虽然我的多动症大脑有时也不擅长这一点。所以这是相互的。但我会和朋友谈论它，她们也开始向我敞开心扉。我甚至从来不知道我的一些最好的朋友也在经历她们所经历的事情。当时有人，我们生完孩子没多久，你知道，彼此之间。她说，我感觉完全一样，除了我在室内和呆在家里的时候。所以我们有相同的症状，但对我们来说，触发因素完全不同。
And again, it's about that understanding and knowing that it's different for everybody. And I knew that I needed help to get out of the house and she knew she needed help to stay in the house. And like now, I just don't think the pandemic helped me particularly because it meant that I could stay in the house and I was safe in my mind um and so I think that's elongated my process to where we are now but I'm very happy to say that uh I have a picture of it actually that I took into the garden center um for lunch on our own and that was only a few months ago um and I got a picture of us and that was a big deal for me so it's not just practicing mindfulness and working in the mental health space doesn't mean that we all have it all together but it means I understand when I need help and I took my time and yeah I'm happy to say we've been out and about now in the summer so it's really good oh I'm really
再说一次，关键在于理解并意识到每个人都是不同的。我知道我需要帮助才能走出家门，而她知道她需要帮助才能待在家里。就像现在，我不认为疫情对我有什么特别的帮助，因为它意味着我可以待在家里，在心理上我是安全的，所以我认为这延长了我的过程，直到我们现在的状态。但我很高兴地说，我甚至有一张照片，是我几个月前带她去园艺中心吃午饭时拍的，那对我来说意义重大。所以，练习正念和在心理健康领域工作并不意味着我们一切都处理得很好，但这意味着我知道自己何时需要帮助，我花了一些时间。是的，我很高兴地说，我们夏天已经出去走动了，这真的很好，哦，我真的
pleased to hear that and I know you've been starting to use mindfulness with your with your little boy as well and that's something that you really advocate teaching young people mindfulness and that might be something that our audience can either do with their own children or in services they might be working with with children and young people could you give us a few top tips for how to build that into working with little ones yeah do you know what and I mentioned this to you before we got started but they just don't question things so much as adults do um if you ask I it will just stay with me forever I had this group of beavers on zoom and they're all messing about I can see them all on their screens and doing this and I asked them just to notice their breathing so we did some
很高兴听到这个消息。我知道你最近也开始和你的小男孩一起练习正念了，你非常提倡教年轻人正念，这可能是我们的听众可以和自己的孩子一起做的事情，或者在他们与儿童和年轻人一起工作的服务中也可以应用。你能给我们一些关于如何将其融入与小孩子工作的建议吗？是的，你知道吗，我在我们开始之前就和你提过，他们不像成年人那样对事情有那么多质疑。如果你问他们，我会永远记住这一点，我曾经在Zoom上带过一组海狸童子军，他们都在屏幕上乱闹，我看着他们，我让他们注意自己的呼吸，所以我们做了一些
breathing we were counting it and they all just stopped and did it no they don't question anything and I talked about mindfulness and I talked about paying attention to you know nice things that kids are going to want to be involved in and I just really think that we can lead by example with this so when it comes to kids like make things fun so with my little boy for example if we're out and about I've said to him before mindfulness means we have a little book that we read and I say what does mindfulness and he says what says, what I can see, what I can smell, what I can hear. So when we're out on a walk, I'll just say to him, what can we smell? What can we see? What can we hear? So it's just practicing a bit of mindfulness. He doesn't need to know why or how or whatever. We're just practicing. And then the same with his breathing. And he even
呼吸练习，我们数着呼吸，他们都停下来照做了。不，他们对任何事情都没有质疑。我谈到了正念，谈到了关注孩子们会感兴趣的美好事物。我真的认为我们可以通过以身作则来引导他们。所以对于孩子，要让事情变得有趣。以我的小男孩为例，如果我们出门在外，我以前告诉过他，正念意味着我们有一本小书要读，我问他正念是什么，他说，我能看到的，我能闻到的，我能听到的。所以当我们散步时，我会问他，我们能闻到什么？我们能看到什么？我们能听到什么？这只是在练习一点正念。他不需要知道为什么或怎么做，我们只是在练习。呼吸也是一样，他甚至
does this, I posted on LinkedIn this morning, he does this to me. So how wonderful is that? I've taught him something. And when he's really upset or crying or say he's fallen over or whatever it is, or he's probably having a tantrum, and we do the breathing technique and hand on the heart. And the other day I really hurt my knee, I really bashed my knee and I had a couple of tears. And he just came over to me and put his hand on me and went it's okay don't worry just breathe that's my boy um and you know like I say just make it fun and the breath is a wonderful one to come back to because everybody's got breath everybody's got breathing and it's something that we can get them to count or we can do it with them sometimes as well if they're really little ones you can put your hand on their heart and ask them to notice the rise and fall um but there's so many lovely things that we can do with
会这样做，我今天早上在领英上发了帖子，他对我做这个动作。这多棒啊！我教了他一些东西。当他非常难过或哭泣，或者摔倒了，或者闹脾气时，我们就会做呼吸技巧，把手放在心口。前几天我的膝盖受了重伤，真的很疼，我流了几滴眼泪。他走过来把手放在我身上说，没关系，别担心，呼吸。这就是我的儿子。就像我说的，让它变得有趣。呼吸是一个很好的回归点，因为每个人都有呼吸，每个人都在呼吸。我们可以让他们数呼吸，或者有时和他们一起做。如果他们还很小，你可以把手放在他们的心口，让他们感受起伏。但我们能和孩子们一起做的事情太多了，
kids and i think it starts with us actually um if we have a bit of a practice then we can share that with them and then we can practice together and what's nicer than that yeah absolutely it sounds like golden moments there but you're right you know breathing is really one of the things that is truly mindful because you can't breathe in the past and you can't breathe in the present. It's only right now. I love that. Is there anything I haven't asked you that you hoped I would? No, I don't think so. I hope that I always get so in the zone and I feel like, oh, did I say everything I wanted to say? I think my overarching thing is I just want people to switch the view of mindfulness into knowing that it's something that is for anybody and everybody.
我认为这实际上始于我们自己。如果我们有一点练习，我们就可以与他们分享，然后我们可以一起练习，还有什么比这更好的呢？是的，绝对是这样，听起来那是黄金时刻。但你是对的，你知道，呼吸确实是真正正念的事情之一，因为你无法呼吸过去，也无法呼吸未来。它只在当下。我喜欢这一点。有什么我没问过你但你希望我问的吗？不，我不这么认为。我希望我总是能进入状态，我感觉，哦，我把我想要说的一切都说了吗？我认为我最核心的观点是，我只是想让人们转变对正念的看法，意识到它是适合任何人和每个人的。
And, yes, some people find it easier than others. Some people resonate with certain things than others. But it really is for everybody. And I just implore people to get started, to just look into it and don't believe that it's this empty mind Zen robot it isn't it's just a practice to understand how your brain works to get to know you a little bit better and then learn some techniques to help you manage the stresses and strains of everyday life which we all have and so yeah and once you've learned whether you do a course or whatever you decide
是的，有些人比其他人更容易上手。有些人对某些事情的共鸣比其他人更强。但它确实适合每个人。我恳请人们开始尝试，去了解它，不要相信它是什么空心禅宗机器人，它不是。它只是一种了解大脑如何运作、更好地了解自己，然后学习一些技巧来帮助你管理日常生活中的压力和紧张的练习，我们每个人都有这些压力。所以，是的，一旦你学会了，无论你是参加课程还是决定做什么，
to do it's free forever like you've got it forever um so actually it's just bloody amazing and I love it you get to keep that in your head don't you you know it becomes part of yourself and your future interactions and I used it even you know this weekend just gone I was um a lovely little cottage with some of my friends a hot tub in the Malvern Hills it was gorgeous um and we were like well let's just just take a moment to just soak this in because you can use it on days that feel tough in future yeah and you know what one of the things sorry that's just reminded me one of the things that I say often is use mindfulness in the good times so of most of the time people come to learn mindfulness because they want to deal with
一旦你做了，它就永远免费了，你永远拥有它。所以实际上，这真是太棒了，我喜欢它。你把它记在脑子里了，不是吗？你知道，它成为了你自己和未来互动的一部分。我甚至在刚过去的这个周末用过它，我和朋友们在一个可爱的小屋里，在马尔文山有一个热水浴缸，太美了。我们当时想，让我们花点时间沉浸其中，因为你可以在未来感觉艰难的日子里使用它。是的，你知道吗，其中一件事，抱歉，这提醒了我，我经常说的一件事是，在美好的时光里使用正念。因为大多数时候，人们来学习正念是因为他们想处理
stress or burnout anxiety or whatever it is but actually we can practice moment when the times are good as well so like yesterday I've gone paddleboarding for the third time my new hobby um and I'd been out I spent some time with my partner and I just sat in the car and I just said I'm really I feel really happy today um and he said why and we talked about it and it was like that acknowledgement that awareness and that being present with the feeling of joy with the feeling of happiness and just when I'm with my friends because you know we're all quite so I say it to them often I love you I'm so happy I'm with you and we acknowledge that as well we don't just have to acknowledge the feelings
压力、倦怠、焦虑或任何其他问题，但实际上我们也可以在美好的时光里练习。就像昨天，我第三次去玩桨板冲浪了，这是我的新爱好。我和伴侣待了一段时间，我坐在车里说，我今天真的感到非常快乐。他问为什么，我们谈论了它。这就像是一种认可，一种觉知，一种与快乐的感觉同在，与幸福的感觉同在。当我与朋友在一起时，因为你知道我们都很……所以我经常对他们说，我爱你们，我很高兴和你们在一起，我们也承认这一点。我们不必只承认那些无益的感觉，
that are unhelpful acknowledge the good we can use mindfulness in the good times as well um and the final thing if it's okay i'll just say is if you feel like you do want to practice mindfulness sometimes it feels a bit self-indulgent to do a mindfulness course but it's just for you um but i think actually we should invest in ourselves and if you can find an eight-week course that really is the start of a habit and I've took many people through an eight-week course doing one-off sessions and stuff is nice um but you either have to commit to doing a course or you need to commit yourself to take the time every week because you need that time to practice um and it will form a habit and you will have it forever um so yeah invest in you I love that how can people connect with you or learn more about your work, Amy, if they'd like to?
也要承认美好的事物。我们可以在美好的时光里使用正念。最后，如果可以的话，我想说的是，如果你觉得你想练习正念，有时参加正念课程会让人觉得有点自我放纵，因为它只是为了你自己。但我认为实际上我们应该投资于自己。如果你能找到一个八周的课程，那确实是养成习惯的开始。我带过很多人参加八周的课程，做一次性的课程之类的也很好，但你要么必须承诺参加课程，要么你需要承诺每周抽出时间，因为你需要时间来练习。它会形成一种习惯，你将永远拥有它。所以，是的，投资你自己。我喜欢这一点。如果人们想联系你或了解更多关于你的工作，艾米，他们该怎么做？
Sure. So I am on Instagram. That's mostly my mum audience. I do a lot of work with mums. This is Amy Polly. I'm on LinkedIn, Amy Polly. And my website is Amy Polly dot com. Thank you so much. It's been an absolute pleasure speaking with you. And I know people will find this super useful. Thank you. Yeah. Thank you find this super useful um thank you yeah thank you again thank you thank you so much thank you so much for listening um we do do um elements of mindfulness and you know compassion and guided imagery within the aspiring psychologist membership um and we might well have Amy coming to the membership shortly too.
当然。我在Instagram上。那主要是我的妈妈受众，我做了很多与妈妈们相关的工作。这是Amy Polly。我在领英上，Amy Polly。我的网站是Amy Polly dot com。非常感谢你。和你交谈真是太愉快了。我知道人们会觉得这非常有帮助。谢谢。是的，谢谢，觉得这非常有帮助。谢谢，是的，再次感谢，谢谢，非常感谢你的倾听。我们确实在有抱负的心理学家会员计划中包含正念、同情心和引导意象的元素，我们很可能很快就会邀请艾米加入会员计划。
If you would like more information or to jump on the waiting list so that you're there ready when the next spaces are available on the 2nd of September, then do head to the link on the show notes, which will tell you how to join the waiting list or you can head to any of my social medias and the link tree link there for link tree dr marianne trent will also guide you straight there but yeah i hope you're having a lovely summer you're being kind to yourself and you're taking time for rest and relaxation please do know that whatever service you're working in can cope for long enough
如果你想要更多信息或加入候补名单，以便在9月2日有空位时准备好，请前往节目说明中的链接，它会告诉你如何加入候补名单，或者你可以前往我的任何社交媒体，那里的Linktree链接，Linktree dr marianne trent也会直接引导你到那里。但是的，我希望你度过一个愉快的夏天，善待自己，并抽出时间休息和放松。请务必知道，无论你在什么服务部门工作，都能支撑足够长的时间，
for you to take some much needed annual leave so thank you for being part of my world and I will look forward to catching up with you again very soon for our next episode of the podcast which comes around at 6am on Mondays but it will be there for you when you're ready. Thank you for being part of my world and speak soon. Take care. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective.
让你休一些急需的年假。所以感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我期待着很快再次与你联系，参加我们的下一期播客，它会在周一早上6点播出，但当你准备好时，它就会在那里等你。感谢你成为我世界的一部分，很快再聊。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。充满了将帮助你获得资格的课程和经验。所以来看看吧。就在这本书里。它是《临床心理学家集体》。
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective Clinical Psychologist Collective book is the book to read for aspiring psychologists. Like most aspiring psychologists, I've read all the books about becoming a clinical psychologist. While other books break down the entry criteria and speak of the course competitiveness, the Clinical Psychologist Collective reveals the varied journeys and individual differences of those who've gotten onto and completed training. It inspired me to embrace my own journey and make the most of my experiences and identity. If you read one book about becoming a clinical psychologist, this is it. If you buy someone who aspires to be a clinical psychologist a book this is it this book will help freshen
它是《临床心理学家集体》，它是《临床心理学家集体》。《临床心理学家集体》这本书是给有抱负的心理学家的必读书。像大多数有抱负的心理学家一样，我读过所有关于成为临床心理学家的书。虽然其他书分解了准入标准并谈论了课程的竞争性，但《临床心理学家集体》揭示了那些已经进入并完成培训的人的多样化旅程和个体差异。它激励我拥抱自己的旅程，并充分利用我的经历和身份。如果你只读一本关于成为临床心理学家的书，那就是这本。如果你给一个渴望成为临床心理学家的人买一本书，那就是这本。这本书将有助于刷新
blossom into a more diverse group of mental health practitioners who use their backgrounds to enhance their ability to support those we serve Thank you. It's right here in this book It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast
成长为一个更多元化的心理健康从业者群体，他们利用自己的背景来增强支持我们所服务对象的能力。谢谢。就在这本书里。它是《临床心理学家集体》。它是《临床心理学家集体》。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》
With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与玛丽安·特伦特博士一起。我叫贾娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。有多少种不同的途径可以达到目标让我感到惊讶，而且没有完美的成为心理学家的方法，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就放不下这本书了。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。